we'll be talking about one shot privacy
auditing an estimation
yeah thank you for the invitation and um
I was going to talk about the classical
things around privacy communication
accuracy but that's what I've been doing
for the past almost two years so I
thought I would talk about something new
um so I hope you were not expecting
something else so this is a joint work
with a lot of colleagues now at Google
some of them are academics as you can
see so Krishna Alina Galen sewang and
Brendan
um and it's going to be about privacy
auditing and estimation if you don't
know what these two words mean it's okay
I'll go over them
um and there's the one shot in it
because we're going to try to do that
with uh if you know an efficient way
essentially so let's talk about auditing
most of the talk is going to be focused
on auditing but towards the end I'll
talk about estimation and not just
auditing and why we might need it
so here's an example of how things can
go wrong in DP somebody writes a paper
comes up with a new method to train
models with differential privacy they
claim that they have found a way to
train really accurate models with very
strong differential criteria so if you
look at their method here it's achieving
an accuracy of 98.7 percent with an
Epsilon of 0.07
this is obviously too good to be true
because it's not true
and there's nothing fundamentally wrong
in their approach so actually they claim
to have uh discovered a new way to bound
user contribution or to do the clipping
step that's uh necessary for dpsgt okay
so just uh FYI there's a lot of there
were a lot of talks on DP but uh
specifically for dpsgd building on
Mario's talk there's this clipping step
that you need and then you add noise
that's calibrated to the sensitivity of
whatever you're clipping so here we're
clipping uh to to to let's say uh unit
board
so in turns out that what they were
implementing is something very different
which is basically they're clipping the
normalized gradients so this one over B
here is actually inside the clip and you
know you can see why this is actually
not going to you know work from the DP
perspective
um because the sensitivity is actually
much higher so you're preserving the
signal but you're not adding the noise
that's needed to get the Privacy
guarantee
all right so obviously one approach for
you to find this out is to go to their
GitHub and read their code line by line
and validate every step to see if it's a
faithful representation of the paper and
then you know say check this is correct
I'm going to use it this is indeed a
breakthrough in DP but you know this is
not something that we can continue to do
as new methods pop up and new approaches
so we're going to use auditing and
auditing is going to hinge on a way of
looking at differential privacy this is
um known as the hypothesis test
operational interpretation of DP goes
back to uh you know the early days of
tpvd so the way DPA can be viewed here
is essentially you have two neighboring
data sets d0 and D1
um they defer only by one record and
you'll pick one of them
and you will train the model with DP on
the selected data set and then you'll
release the result the output of the
algorithm to some auditor and they have
the job of deciding if you picked d0 or
D1 okay
so what they will do is they will choose
a rejection region R and if the output
Falls in this region R they'll say I'm
going to reject the null hypothesis so
I'll say this was trained on D1 and if
it's not an R they'll accept the null
hypothesis simple hypothesis uh testing
binary hypothesis testing and um you
know we can prove that DP is equivalent
to providing a guarantee uh on this the
power of this binary hypothesis test so
if you look at the ROC curve then there
is this Pentagon Pentagon shaped curve
that's dictated by Epsilon and Delta uh
obviously the the the the
attacker would love to operate at this
point where you know the the the false
positive rate is zero the true positive
rate is one but it's forcing the auditor
to be in that region
okay so this is something that is
important
if you have any questions feel free to
invite me because we're going to build
on this
all right so with this interpretation of
differential privacy
um people can now audit via what's known
as membership inference attacks they're
going to crucially rely on this idea of
DP is a hypothesis test we're going to
take a data set so for this talk think
of this data set as maybe the end this
data set or em this data set but it
could be any data sets you could even
craft it adversarially if you want and
you add to it one uh we call it Canary
example so it's either a training
example or some sort of a model update
to get D Prime from d
and you will select the or D Prime and
you will train your model
with DP with whatever epsilons and
Deltas you've picked
and then you'll
give the output to an auditor
who's going to determine whether or not
it was you know from D let's say
and you're going to repeat it many times
so this process is repeated thousands
ten tens of thousands even hundreds of
thousands of times and you'll assess the
performance of this auditor so every
time you run this the auditor makes a
decision D or D Prime so either that was
correct or wrong and you do it let's say
ten thousand times so you have ten
thousand binary values zero ones
determining if the auditor was correct
or wrong and you're you'll use the
sequence of zeros and ones to compute
the false positive rates and the false
negative rate and then you'll take those
things and compute an estimate of the
Epsilon from them
and there's a way to actually uh you
know be confident about your estimate to
give a lower amount and we'll touch on
it in a bit
so you're going to trust the the
personal Publishers data of this
mechanism to take it out or how do you
choose a Delta
um it's the designer's choice
so so yeah so so again somebody posted
code on GitHub saying this algorithm is
differentially private according to my
paper at the chief state of the art it
beats everything out there and I'm
trying to
validate this their algorithm is
correctly implemented or invalidated or
you know invalidate maybe results they
they gave them their pay
the DNB Prime change across these times
or is it the fixed you could change them
there's no need for DND Prime to be
fixed
as long as yeah every time you're
instantiating a a problem you know with
the right neighboring data sets but then
the randomness would also come that are
Randomness on the choice of data set
also should come right yeah I mean if
you change them the variance of your
estimate would be higher right so you
would need to take into account that
okay so so this is the general recipe
and it has two issues one is you need to
craft the poison yes
I'm sorry so
for any auditor when you compute those
false positive rate and false negative
phase you get an uh lower amount
it's an auditor
yes and and technically
here
exactly to to to maximize the balance
yeah great
sometimes it's obvious what to use but
sometimes it's not obvious and where
it's not obvious you need to design a
threshold for the binary hypothesis test
all right so one question here is we
need to craft this canary training
example
um and you know the the better of a job
we do the better of an estimate we get
and that's not an easy question
but the even harder I think problem here
is that we need to retrain the model
many many times like a thousand times is
the minimum but you know you'll see that
people have free trained it a hundred
thousand times
this might be okay if the model is
actually very small tens hundreds
thousands of parameters but with today's
large-scale models and the hundreds of
billions of parameters we cannot afford
doing anything like that
so that's a big problem
I mean if if you're uh job is just to
say that
this algorithm is correctly implemented
you can do it via that you might
actually do unit testing on the code
testing edge cases but it depends
sometimes uh you only have some API
access you know and you can train
certain classes of models for instance
okay all right so in this talk what
we're going to be primarily focused on
is
solving these two issues and the most
important one is this the one where you
have to retrain the model many many
times
and first we need to understand where is
that coming from why do we have to
retrain the model many times
the issue here is that we want to be
confident in our estimate of the Epsilon
so if somebody for instance is telling
you uh this model is uh or this
algorithm is Epsilon Delta DP with an
Epsilon of say 0.1 or 0.07 as it was in
that paper
um you would like to pick here a point
that's outside the region that DP gives
you and you want to make sure that the
confidence intervals
are small enough that none of the edges
of this box are touching or overlapping
with this region that's how you know
that with high probability you know the
Epsilon is actually larger than what
it's advertised
because we want to be very confident in
refuting the claim that somebody is
making and so you might wonder what is
this box and what's the width of this
box well I said you have sequences of
zeros and ones that you're using to
estimate false positive and false
negative rates these are they're only
IID random variables and we have a lot
of results on how these things
concentrate and that's how we
essentially can derive proper bounds
with proper confidence intervals we use
one of these uh well-known results
but what's very common between them
maybe they have different constants they
all behave like root one by n and that's
why we need the number of samples to be
large because we want the width of this
box to be small enough
so for instance if it was a randomized
response that kind of uh achieves two
comma 10 to the negative 5 DP but
they're claiming that say that it's 0.8
then you know this box can be wide it's
okay if you look at the region of a
randomized response here it's okay if I
could find a canary in this point here a
strong good counter example if this box
is wide enough it's good enough for me
to refute that claim but if I'm using
the gaussian mechanism and it's iterated
over many training routes which is the
case with dpsgd the actual region of the
algorithm is actually very different and
what you're trying where it violates
that claim is really in here
and this is precisely why you want this
box to be very small because you're
searching for in this case very little
violations
this is why it gets really hard it's all
about the tails in some sense
for instance if you look at uh the paper
that I opened with uh my colleagues at
Google and their collaborators were able
to refute that claim
via this approach so they used exactly
this membership inference attack to show
that uh you know their algorithm is
achieving an Epsilon of 2.79 so they
were claiming a much much smaller
Epsilon but for them to be able to do
that confidently they had to retrain the
model 200 000 times so their end here
was two hundred thousand and and that
that was kind of critical for them to be
able to make this claim confidently
all right so one way to overcome this
problem is to say you know what instead
of actually comparing two neighboring
data sets that only defer by one record
what we're going to do is we're going to
make these two data sets defer by K
records and we're going to test for the
presence and absence of each one of them
so in some sense every time I run I get
k-tests as opposed to a single test so
now I have K binary quantities so I've
in some sense expanded my sample size
and you would hope that this would give
some improvements by the way this idea
appeared recently in this paper there's
another paper that Ilya is on as well uh
sorry for the missing reference in a
different context under label DP but it
has appeared that's what I'm saying in a
bunch of papers
so this could in theory reduce the
confidence interval by a factor of 1 by
K or root One by K suchd
um and that's great but the problem with
this approach is that now the
neighboring data sets are not deferring
by one record they're deferring by K
records and if we want to be absolutely
correct this goes back to the morning
talk by Ilia we have to use what's known
as group privacy when K things change
it's not just uh e to the Epsilon it's e
to the K Epsilon
again this is group group privacy so
technically now we're not testing
Epsilon we're testing K Epsilon and
we're in some sense back to the same
problem that we had before
we have to be very careful in doing this
all right so here's how we will try to
resolve this issue
first we'll go back to this picture we
need to somehow form many data sets that
defer only by one record as you can see
here there's a bunch of them
I haven't done anything yet I'm still
training the model many times multiple
times three in this case so we're not
going to do that instead what we're
going to consider is a data set that has
all the records and then a neighboring
data set that just misses one of them
all right so if you can see here I still
have you know three distinct pairs so I
haven't reduced the number of training
runs yet but I'm just thinking of the
problem a little different so instead of
just adding one record and not have it I
have one base data set D that has all
the records and then K different let's
say neighboring data sets each that
leaves one out I'm going to call this a
leave one out construction okay
so far nothing happened except that
we're just looking at it a little
differently
so the way we're going to Now train is
we're going to train on this data set
that has all the canaries
single model trained once with whatever
algorithm you're using with whatever
property DP Properties it has and then
the distinguisher will have
to check for each Canary
if it was there or not okay
and from that use the K uh binary values
to estimate the false positives and
false negative rates now you might feel
a little you know squeaky about this
like what have we done you know uh
what's happened and and
there's a big question mark here
which is like how do we test something
that's that
wasn't used when we haven't trained on
something that didn't have it
it turns out this is the second or third
key ingredient that's going to be very
critical
the way we're going to construct these
canaries is at random
and we want to pick them all K of them
from the same distribution
so that they're exchangeable so
statistically they look alike they're
not alike obviously once you've sampled
you have an instance these things are
not the same but statistically speaking
because they all come from the same
underlying distribution they are
exchangeable
so this will be important and here's one
Concrete Construction that I will be
using in this talk which is I'm going to
take those Canary uh examples not to be
as training examples but rather as model
updates so think of them as
d-dimensional vectors where D is the
number of parameters of the model and
they're picked at random uniformly Trend
them from the units here and you can
then scale them if the clip Norm is
different than one okay so there's a
well defined distribution over the units
here the D dimensional unit sphere and I
could sample from it very efficiently
so they're choosing uniformly from The
Unit D sphere and the test statistic
that the auditor is going to use is the
cosine angle between the final model and
that sampled uh canary from the unit
sphere so we're going to look at that
angle and this angle is simply the dot
product normalized right so you look at
the dot product between the canary and
the final model that's the output of the
algorithm and then you normalize it by
the Norms then that's the cosine angle
and that's going to be our test
statistic So based on that cosine angle
we're going to either say the canary was
in or out
okay if it's in we expect that dot
product to spike up because the model
would have seen the canarians or the dot
product these things should be aligned
somehow it's going to be large and if
not it's going to be small
um yeah the cosine increases
but now here's the interesting thing
the interesting thing is that
if we use this construction we don't
need to train the model on any of these
data sets foreign
distribution for this test statistic
without even training the model
so in other words let's pick one of them
let's say we pick the first D Prime here
on the slide
and we're trying to test
this red
sample Canary
you can essentially
write the distribution of the cosine
between that Canary and the final model
because the final model has never seen
that thing that was sampled uniformly
from a sphere and in this case it's
there's like literally the proof is so
easy to actually figure out this
distribution in closed form and so you
have the null distribution and it's
going to be exactly the same for all
these D primes I mean this is why we
need statistically exchangeable uh this
property okay I'm not showing it on the
slide but you take my word if you can
take my word for it that would be great
you could really find that distribution
yeah
it's mine it's final model after
training with all the canaries or is it
trained on the Y thesis yeah so let me
go back to slide so we train once that's
why we call it one shot we train ones on
all of them right so here when we form a
binary hypothesis test for each one of
them we have K binary hypothesis tests
for each one of them the null is going
to be that that thing let's say the red
thing did not exist we have the
distribution of the test statistic in
the coastboard so for each one of the K
binary hypothesis tests we know the null
null distribution and for the
alternative distribution you can get it
from here
remember you have the same input data
set
the final model came
yes
a few measures depending between the
final model
how do you use science it's a survey of
Randomness right what I observe every
time I run this algorithm it's not going
to be the same but we know the
distribution of the
field so if I compute that test
statistic
if let's say the rent record was not
there
I and I'm able to run this training
algorithm 200 000 times and look at the
cosine angle it'll form a very clean
very nice distribution but I can
pre-compute like I know it without even
having to run
that's the beauty of the design of the
canaries
this turns out to be actually key yep
I guess at this point I'm not sure what
the rule of K is right like why can't
kbn like why can't I do it for all well
you you you
what you want is um sorry what why can't
K I mean like why don't I use all of the
data as I mean by doing why do you
specifically pick K Which is less than I
mean I guess in this picture the case
three right yeah so I can't be just be n
okay
you want this K Canary records
uh to be sampled from this distribution
because this is the distribution that
you know the null uh you know the
distribution under the null hypothesis
score right that's one thing and then
the other thing is you're brand in too
many of them
you can start putting a lot of them at
one point they start becoming correlated
and you know depending on the model
dimensionality it's
they start becoming correlated then
testing their presence
becomes misleading and I'll get to it in
a bit actually I'll make another
argument why you don't why you want to
keep the case small it's because it's
kind of uh it's like further shorter
your scat if you inject too many
canaries you change the object that you
are measuring like that right your want
to measure privacy of a particular
process
that works on a relative distribution if
it's not changing the distribution
you're by measuring something else
basically group privacy one point one
space records become strongly important
I don't believe that
this is a randomized breakfast they're a
little bit uncorrelated
um it's high dimensional High
dimensional vectors like the right right
back but if D is not very high if their
number relative to D let's say d is a
million and I add a million canaries
into my training set and obviously
there's strong correlations not because
no privacy will say that the behavior of
a trade model with canaries will change
from the train model without canaries
that will help
just don't want to change it
dramatically
okay I think I'll get to also something
that will clarify
so yeah this is important that it's
computable in closed form
um and yeah I mean we talked a lot about
this so I don't think I need to spend a
lot of time but why why are we picking
random canaries I mean you would have
thought that maybe if I were to inspect
the data set in the model architecture I
could craft something that's
specifically designed to maximize the
difference between D and D Prime and I
believe that that may be the case but
because of high dimensionality and mere
orthogonality in high dimensionality we
kind of get that for free we don't
really need to inspect the data or the
model architecture to know something
about the task and go solve an
optimization problem to find the optimal
canaries for a specific task or model
architecture so we're arguing here that
this distribution is leads to uh strong
canaries by Design
and that that's that's good and we don't
need to know anything about it say for
instance we need to use it at Google and
different teams are using this algorithm
to train very different algorithms on
very different data domain we don't need
to sit down with every team and figure
out what canaries we want to use for
each and every single domain we don't
need to train for instance craft
canaries for images versus speech versus
text so on and so forth this is just
like random vectors and high dimensional
space it works beautifully for
everything and this is the intuition
behind it because it's nearly orthogonal
in high dimensional spaces
all right
um so for the gaussian mechanism we can
actually write a theorem this is the
informal statement of it which is that
as long as you know you have D and K
large and K shouldn't scale as fast as d
then the estimate that you get from our
uh one shot so what you're going to do
here is basically you have a sum of D
dimensional vectors so you have your
true vectors those are the vectors that
you're Computing the sum query on and
then you add those cake and Aries and
you release the whole thing with
obviously the DP noise and what we can
prove is that the estimates that we get
from this method asymptotically uh give
you the correct Epsilon that you're
trying to compute
okay so this is just an asymptotic proof
of correctness if we didn't have this we
would have not used this method to begin
with this is not telling us much this is
just focusing on one small narrow you
know sum query and it's making sure that
our Approach at least passes a sanity
check so I don't want to make a huge
deal about this theorem I just want to
say that it works as intended okay but
this doesn't give us confidence
intervals something that remember we
actually really needed to be able to
confidently give lower bounds on the
epsilons
so we need to work a little harder to
get confidence intervals
okay
the asymptotics here are over D there's
no n here say one shot okay so the
asymptotics are over D and K
so you let D and K go to Infinity k at a
slightly uh slower uh pace and you prove
that the Epsilon is converging and this
uh convergence is uh almost sure
convergence because the F this is a
random process right so
all right so let me let me uh now uh
pivot to something that uh we don't have
the paper on archive for yet but it's
going to be on archive soon uh and try
to understand how can we generalize
everything I talked about so that we get
rigorous lower bounds from it so we need
to derive confidence intervals and be
confident about the estimates that we're
giving
so the first ingredient or the first
step in this process is to actually
rethink differential privacy from
scratch from first principles and it
really isn't that big of a difference
but it's actually very important so what
we're seeing is that
a mechanism is called Epsilon Delta
lifted DP
if it satisfies this thing which looks a
lot like DP so what is the difference
the difference here is the probability
is not taken just over the randomness of
the algorithm it's also taken over the
randomness in the two neighboring data
sets the zero and D1 and also the
rejection region so everything can be
randomized all right so now you have a
distribution p over d0 and D1 and the
rejection region
and
what you want is this distribution over
both the randomness of the algorithm and
P
to satisfy the bound
and what we can show it's actually not
too difficult to show that these two are
if and only if so the classical notion
of DP and this lifted notion are
actually very equivalent
so what this gives us is that now
instead of picking a point here where
essentially finding a random counter
example
and we can use that randomness to search
over canaries okay so this is how we're
going to generalize the slide that we
had before now we're being very rigorous
so we're not doing just one shot we're
going to actually train more than one
model here but you know you'll see that
it gives us gain
so either you have the K random canaries
drawn from a distribution or the K minus
one so that you have proper neighboring
between d0 and D1 and you'll train the
model on either d0 or D1 and then you'll
ask yourself if C1 was there or
something else C1 Prime
okay
so here's an example
um in this situation again it's not one
shot we're going to do with n times
each time we're going to generate cake
and Aries from a distribution of choice
the one that I presented before is a
valid one but it applies more broadly so
you can pick something else
and then you construct d0 which is say
your favorite data set mnist with K
minus one canaries
and then D1 has all the canaries
but now you're going to train two models
one on d0 and one on D1
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to compute that test
statistic
on the you know on D1 the model that was
trained on D1 with all of those canaries
and then
when you're doing the null hypothesis
you're going to generate Now new
canaries
those are the things that you actually
didn't use C1 Prime through c one CK
Prime
and that's how you're going to compute
the null hypothesis okay this is all
done I mean you might it might seem a
little bit too much but it's all done to
maintain that d0 and D1 equivalence
that that we really want to maintain
okay
so we're doing n iterations and in every
iteration we're adding K canaries
please feel free to interrupt me if this
is not clear and then we will use this
information to estimate the true
positive rate and the false positive
rate
so then if somebody picks a Delta we
could compute the the Epsilon from using
this expression
and again it's important what was
important is we're using the Epsilon
Delta lifted DP notion and we're using
the IID exchangeable Canary sampling
approach
now here's the thing if these things
here
were truly independent
then we'll get that root K gain in the
confidence intervals
but we have no guarantee that these
statistics this Burn only random
variables are actually truly independent
right that's that's the issue that we're
facing here
so that dependence is unknown so what we
can do is we can
go back to giving a confidence interval
that only depends on N because where the
outer loop is n times so we can ignore
the fact that we've added cake and Aries
and just forfeit the gains we get from
that
but that's really not what we're after
because if we wanted that we wouldn't
have used the cake in Aries thing or we
could use more interesting concentration
results for Bern only random variables
that could have dependence so they can
be correlated if you go back to your
statistics textbook there's a lot of
these second order type result and
fourth order results
and without going into too many details
but what we could show is that as long
as the correlation between these random
variables is well behaved ideally if
it's like on the order of One by K
suddenly we reduce the confidence
intervals to you know root one by NK so
we got that extra factor of K that we
were looking for
but again this needs to be well behaved
so now it's a question of for a specific
construction for a specific application
is this correlation well behaved yes or
no and you know you can try it for the
gaussian mechanism
put all the pieces together and what you
will see here is that let's say here the
true Epsilon is two and we're trying to
falsify a range of epsilons somebody
claims it's 0.2 or 0.4 0.61 and so forth
how many samples do we need in order to
confidently falsify that no it's not 0.8
because the true Epsilon is actually two
and you'll see that if you don't use
this trick this is the curve that shows
you uh how many samples you need to to
falsify and then if you use the K Canary
trick with all those added details then
you'll get good gain you know for 0.8
you'll get 16x gain and then for 0.7 or
something like that you'll get 4X gain
from this approach and again this is
something that is provable in the sense
that you can you can be confident about
you could look at this correlation for
discussion mechanism and you'll see that
you know indeed it actually behaves like
One by K it's not exactly one by K but
it behaves like One by K this is
empirical correlation here all right so
I think I'll stop here uh I think we're
at time right and I'll take questions
think better thanks
so while the next Peter speaker sets up
any questions yeah quick possibly
impossible question uh I think so it
gives you lower back on Epsilon is there
any way to get another round that's
that's what's going to be in the next
part of the talk
um which is basically there are many
applications in which we don't want to
just audit or falsify uh we might want
to estimate the actual next one because
the DP analytic Epsilon makes some
assumptions that do not necessarily hold
for instance one thing we actually saw
today in this Workshop is that you
simply get amplification by iterations
right
you could eventually run the dpsd
algorithm indefinitely and the Epsilon
would just not go Unbound for going with
privacy accounting privacy accounting
will tell you the more you train the
more the leakage will grow but you know
we now have some evidence that that's
not the case in practice right so we
don't fully understand these results yet
and you might want to compute that
Epsilon and be confident about it and I
was going to show a lot of experiments
that we've done where we're kind of
confident that we're giving the right
epsilons but we don't have formal proofs
or you know upper boundedness or
anything like that so that's an open
question that I think this community
will follow is best suited to try to
tackle
like under what assumptions and
constructions and classes of adversaries
can we not only just give a lower bound
and be confident about it but also show
some form of an upper bound
let's think Peter again
is a few